had about mesignamide. So of course, everyone talk, it's all about cerebron, right? And
so Dr. Zonder showed this and alluded to it. Why are these drugs more potent? Because they're
more potent because of binding to cerebron and put into the closed active confirmation. If you
look at this binding affinity, it's significantly better for mesignamide over, you know, lead and
POM certainly. And, you know, I guess possibly over Iber too, but there's, we're not going to
be comparing those two really, but just to speak to this more in concepts. For me, the interesting
thing about mesignamide is its other effects. And I'm going to show you one of the trials that Dr.
John and Karen was running at City of Hope, sort of, what's the word, capitalizing on these effects.
And these effects are its effects on T-cell fitness and exhaustion and really reducing
exhaustion. And so, you know, I'm going to show you one of the trials that Dr. John and Karen
were running at City of Hope, sort of, what's the word, capitalizing on these effects. And so, you
know, I'm going to show you one of the trials that Dr. John and Karen was running at City of Hope, sort
of, what's the word, capitalizing on these effects. And so, you know, I'm going to show you one of the
effects. And so, you know, I'm going to show you one of the effects. And so, you know, I'm going to
and helping activate T-cells. The other thing I didn't show here, but there's preclinical data
all suggesting that mesignamide may also help with T-cell trafficking. So of course, let's first see,
does this drug work in myeloma, right? So just looking at the combination studies, you know,
clearly, I'm not going to go to the details of this study, but of course, advanced disease,
you could see here, the prior therapies, the usual IMID-PI combinations, about a third in this
initial study were CD38 refractory. So you could argue not the worst of the worst. But, you know,
certainly we did see responses with the mesi-bortezomib-dex combination, pretty decent
PFS of about 20 months. Though again, you know, one could argue, you know, less so in the
CD38 refractory, about 16 months, but still, that's not so bad. And in fact, somewhat reminiscent
of some of the bispecifics we've seen, though these were less heavily pretreated patients.
I think everyone has seen this slide. Dr. Richardson loves this slide. Tom is nodding his head.
But this also brings to the question of how are we really going to use mesi and how are we using it
now? So here you do see responses in extramedullary disease.
And this is Dr. John Akiram's trial, which he has almost completed accrual. This is IDA cell,
then followed by mesi maintenance for 12 cycles at 0.3 and 0.6 milligrams. He's already up to the
0.6 milligram cohort. And as I said, he's almost completed this trial. So we hope to have some data
to present later this year. I can just say, though, it has been extremely well tolerated.
And of course, we have the successor trials here. So mesi, bortezomib, dex versus PBD. Again,
one to three prior lines of therapy and not PI refractory because of the control arm. So,
you know, relatively less heavily pretreated patients. So again, this becomes the question,
maybe we can have this discussion with the panel. Where are we going to use mesi? You know,
is it going to be in this situation? Successor two, of course, we had some early kind of
data of this, a successor to mesi KD versus the control arm of KD, one or more prior lines of
therapy. And I think, you know, Jeff alluded to how is this going to stack up compared to
bispecific data? We don't really know. We just have this right now, right, in terms of positive
results in terms of PFS. But again, it may all become down to what are the hazard ratios and
what is that PFS going to look like?
So, you know, in summary, you know, we clearly see mesigamide as an active drug. It has,
you know, activity in combination with proteasome inhibitors. And, you know,
we have used it as single agent in terms of expanded access trials in the post-CAR-T relapse
setting and have seen activity, which again, is nice to have a non-T cell dependent
option. Really the big, big question, and as Jeff alluded to, what is really going to be the best
partner and where are we going to use it? So this sort of unmet needs space, what is the unmet needs
there? To me, it is really in that post-CAR-T relapse space and in terms of combinations. So
thank you.